the total support of the  military-industrial complex an empire  and war by Barack Obama Hillary Clinton  is staggering I mean it was staggering  our it would even blush Nixon no I you  know Reagan you know when he called the  evil empire the Soviet Union when he saw  hunt 200,000 people marching for nuclear  arms-control  and he saw well-dressed Republicans  among them he turns around and he breaks  crown with Gorbachev so and it was Nixon  who went to China you know I was  Kissinger and and they weren't there  don't get freaked out by challenges from  the right like Buchanan the Democrats go  nuts from challenges from the left I  mean we were sued 24 times in 12 weeks  in the summer of 2004 to get a soft 1  state ballot after another